this year's price is about light the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has
decided to award the 2014 Nobel Prize in
Physics to Professor isamu akasaki at
male university in Nagoya and Nagoya
University Japan professor Hiro she
Amano at Nagoya University Japan and
professor judean nakamura at University
of California Santa Barbara we saw for
the invention of efficient blue
light-emitting diodes which has enabled
bright and energy-saving white light
sources
professor Bedell Singh will now give us
a short summary in English please
so today the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences is awarding the Nobel Prize in
Physics for the invention of blue
light-emitting diodes red and green LEDs
have been around for many years but the
blue was really missing this lamp
contains three LEDs one red one green
and one blue if you combine these colors
you get white light this is something
that Isaac Newton showed already in 1671
thanks to the blue LED we can now get
white light sources which have very high
energy efficiency and very long lifetime
this LED technology is now replacing
older technologies in fact many of you
carry this technology in your pocket
their flashlights and also the screen of
modern smartphones uses LED technology
professor Ling and as will now continue
and give you some of the details
and we will continue to look at the
history of lighting which has been
around now for the last few million
years of human evolution we started out
by burning fuels inside lamps in the
geometry quite similar to that lamp we
see over there however that has mainly
be used here at kV a using incandescent
lighting an electric light over the last
hundred years or so since Edison
invented these things the fluorescent
lamp was introduced somewhere in the
early 20th century and then we saw much
much later the arrival of the lighting
element that we are now celebrating in
this year's Nobel Prize and what you see
is of course an enormous increase of the
power efficiency of the use of
electrical energy in generating light
now something like a fourth of our
electricity consumption in most
industrialized economies goes to
illumination so these effects having
much less much more light for much less
electricity is really going to have a
big impact on our modern civilisation we
see that impact you see it in the
streets you see it on the cars you see
it in the lights you see it in new
optical environments like this one from
a festival of light somewhere in Japan
and they are all based on the use of
these light emitting diodes they come in
different colors not only white but blue
red and green as we saw here and they
have not only the advantage of it but
much better using the electrical energy
they also give a very much longer life
time maybe a hundred times longer than
that of the standard incandescent lamp
that is now being going into retirement
also it doesn't bring the mercury long
that intermediate generation of
fluorescent tubes is contributing as a
problem to industrial civilization so we
will most certainly be able to use these
technology but it took a long while to
arrive at this possibility the red LEDs
have been around since the early 1960s
the green LEDs some years later
advances in semiconductor technology
using this bandgap semiconductors with
different band gaps lies at the highest
light lies at the base of this but the
blue thing the blue light-emitting diode
was very very difficult to accomplish
not that there was a lack of effort
there was continuous efforts in
industries to generate blue
light-emitting diodes
because today with the advantage of
having these available we can generate
all those colors we can combine in color
mixing with three different colors in
the individual lamp or we can use as you
find mostly may be on the market today a
blue or UV emitting LED illuminating a
thin layer absorbing this energy and
converting it to other colors the
structure of these lamps are very
similar to what you have at the base of
your semiconductor electronics that's
driving the information technology a
diode the combination of semiconductor
materials where you have one layer
carrying holes one layer carrying
electrons they transport these charges
at two different energy levels but when
they meet in this intermediate layer the
active layer they recombine and when
they fall into each other they turn up
and turn light on that was liked that
worry there so this is the physical
mechanism that lies at the heart of this
device and our laureates of of this year
have contributed greatly by the
inventions that made it possible to grow
the gallium nitride and alloys of
gallium nitride materials in the
particular geometry suitable for
building such diodes you have to be able
to grow these and that was attempted for
three decades before the in the
inventions of of akasaki
Amana and Nakamura you have to be able
to form these diodes and there was a
great problem with passivation of the
dopants being used to create these it
was solved by discoveries and inventions
in these Japanese labs and you have to
introduce more colors and you
to build them into structures which well
confine the electrons and the whole
searching to each other in order to
generate light emission and these are
the structures as you find it today a
great number of abbreviations on top of
each other each layer may be a fraction
of the micrometer thin deposited from
the vapor phase in big synthesis
machines what you see in the in the at
the market might be a light bulb like
this whether tiny tiny speck of matter
with this structure sub my sub
millimeter size is emitting quite a bit
of light today or the yesterday when
this figure was compiled by satellite
photographers of NASA this is why we see
light being generated in the dust really
kaanum is mainly with the great urban
areas of the world but of course the
access to electricity is very weak in
many areas of the globe there is no
electricity net they don't have the
electrical power generation accessible
this is changing because solar lanterns
being used to generate light with little
electricity helped out in balancing the
systems where you have solar
photovoltaic plants and store them in
batteries for use at night so in the
future I believe this map will look
different and this is very much in the
in the mind of Earth Nobel who wanted to
give his prize for the to the inventions
for the better benefit of mankind and
this is why we award this year's prize -
akasaki Amano and Nakamura Thank You
professor
ingen s and we are now trying to see if
we can get professor Nakamura on the
phone I should say it's about three
o'clock in the morning and I think I
woke professor Nakamura up just 15
minutes ago so I say good morning
professor Nakamura are you there yeah
good morning I'm here
yeah and congratulations I'm sitting
here in the session Hall at the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences and we have
a press conference with many interested
journalists from Swedish and
international press and all your ready
to take some questions from them
professor Nakamura yes I'm ready
okay yeah okay yeah do we have any
questions for professor Nakamura
good morning professor congratulations
omedetou gozaimasu we have already read
we have already heard some things that
about the significance of your
discoveries could you please in your
words tell us about the what do you
think is the significance of your
discoveries oh my work is I think the
technique he clarifies the why we
couldn't measure their current quality
you places in Memphis is a deeper stuff
are accredited rarity or glide path
Meyer in Iowa is a five-night read it
was very difficult to hear your your
your your voice is breaking up here
thank you
all right bitch gosh do we have some
other questions yes congratulations how
did you feel being woken up like this in
the middle of the night with a message
that you have won the Nobel Prize
hello oh okay no yeah I don't know if
you had the question was just how they
did it what did it feel like to be
waking up in the middle of the night
with the message that you'd received a
Nobel Prize
oh yeah I'm believing it's me pizza oh
yeah yeah crazy yeah
unbelievable yeah okay in well thank you
professor Nakamura and and from all of
us here we congratulate you once again
and and perhaps you can stop perhaps you
can go sleep a few hours but then I
think there will be a lot of media
outside your house so thanks again
oh yeah thanks a lot so order now any
questions - - to our experts here at the
pandal something that you would like to
to to have clarified
please
my name is Shiva Chen access zone from
freelancer for China radio and I heard
these prices about the energy in LED so
when you consider this price is do you
consider the element that will be
contributed to the society in practice
more than in theory my response would be
saying that that we were cherishing the
tradition that Alfred Nobel who was a
great inventor he wanted his price to be
given to inventions for the benefits of
mankind and that's what we emphasize
today is the usefulness of this thing
and usefulness in so many applications
we emphasize very strongly the fact that
it can be used for light lighting but
we've seen over the years how these
inventions of the blue light-emitting
diode was used in the blue laser diodes
used for optical storage how coming
generations of of communication will
rely on the use of use of light rather
than radio waves in life I rather than
Wi-Fi and how you can use these blue or
UV light in order to sterilize water
there are so many uses of this and and
the uses I think is what would make
Alfred Nobel very happy something to add
or I can I can add that this is really
an invention price is not a maybe less a
discovery price as other price but
invention price and in this type of
price we really emphasize the usefulness
of the of the invention and this is the
case in this case do we have some more
questions
if not a I like to talk we have a
question over there yeah
hello I'm Oliver G from the local
sweden's news in English it was a little
hard to understand mr. Nakamura on the
phone perhaps you could recount how it
was to ring up and let him know that
he'd won the prize and we could hear
from your side you're from from my side
we reached two of the three laureates
professor Amano happened to be on a
plane from Japan to France at this very
moment so we couldn't reach him but we
could reach professor Okazaki and and
professor Nakamura and of course they
are thrilled of getting this price and I
think actually they were not prepared
for it that they had not been waiting
all day and all night for this call and
if you happen to be on a plane I think
that's how it is and of course it's a
fantastic experience for us too to be
the first to to to wake them up or call
them in the evening and congratulate
them achieving the Nobel Prize in
Physics so that's a great honor on our
part okay if there are no other
questions I'd like to to end this press
conference and see you tomorrow when we
are announcing the chemistry prize at
the same time and in the same hole thank
you very much